there isn't much left of bakmut to fight
for but Ukraine and Russia continue to
throw soldiers and materiel into one of
the bloodiest battles of the war in
Ukraine the head of Russia's Wagner
mercenary group says his forces have
taken control of the eastern part of the
city
is
[Music]
in a video released on Wednesday of
gaining prison is shown talking to
Wagner mercenaries who are complaining
they're running out of ammunition
Wagner Fighters have been leading the
Russian campaign to seize bahmut
Trijicon has accused Russia's defense
minister Sergey shogu of treason the
withholding supplies of Munitions to his
Fighters Munitions earned short supply
two for Ukraine's forces EU defense
ministers have been meeting to discuss a
plan for member states to pool resources
to buy ammunition
NATO Secretary General says bakmut may
fall to Russia in the coming days this
does
not necessarily uh reflect any turning
point of the war and
um and uh and uh it just highlights that
we should not underestimate Russia we
must continue to provide support to
Ukraine
Ukraine's military released a video of a
commander visiting troops in bakmut
Alexander cersky tells the men they're
in the hottest spot
is of little strategic value for both
the Ukrainian military and Wagner
mercenaries have said they're using this
battle to deplete and divert their
adversaries resources from elsewhere
along the front line
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera